hello welcome to zero playing Grand
Master I think I'll go koi so no name of
the Kaiser Gianna and will play the
London system Wow again it's not a big
thriller of an opening but no we we see
nowadays and your top-level chance that
some sometimes people play there okay
I'm trying this set up here with p6 yeah
I think this is a very decent setup for
black ideas to play Knight to f5 Bishop
d7 night 36 and ultimately use the e4
square yeah i'm currently wondering if
you if i can write a 5v can take it
yeah but it's very dead sets probably
dubious fam taking on f6 to see to let
me I'll be pretty surprised if this is
this is Simon something great wine it's
a normal theoretical line and this is
never played it's probably some some
reason for that okay g6 and Bishop f6
community exes it's nonsense yeah here
here by one pin so we just very it just
gives me the bishops here for nothing
right ok so I'm going to try to open up
the queenside him with before coming
yeah this is interesting well but if you
take the app Bishop c8 and they will get
a bishop to our five which is pretty
terrible so I'm going to open up the
position here now he's just shooting for
instant moves the whole time why exactly
I can't think I'm taking this happy that
position opens up here the Knights will
have good squares but still so what to
do now I can also go bishop see it back
but of course you won't take it just
won't take it like that and drag him
hmm yeah I cannot take this now which is
kind of unfortunate there should be
seven that's nuts is six ok
again the Knights now look quite good so
maybe I've misjudged this now if I must
have misplayed that in the last couple
of news because initially black was in
excellent shape very clearly i think but
not anymore amazing huh with only one
know what i did wrong i scored 96 mm-hmm
I'll navigate this probably too
superficial level
ya know this is just good for white I
guess not quite sure how exactly you
should do it but to buy this of course
better even though I'm not totally sure
what what is he doing now 9726 mega i'm
still holding this somehow rook age
seven maybe
I can actually check your first song
okay okay Chad doesn't work you can
actually take 180 check takes a default
check time morning
now it's got this chick coming or okie 7
now can I think I'm lost him I think I'm
not just my lamb resigns it's got rookie
70 f 7 as is a kind of a shame always
hated if they play completely this is
just bad for wider and pretty pretty
obviously bad but I didn't didn't take
use of it now it gives me two bishops
against two nights and there's no
compensation for white for this but I
played it badly probably making the
position to static with b5 and things
like that maybe even the capture is
wrong I don't know the engine wants to
do this which makes lots of sense
playing f6 next and kicking this back
the week 43 is another thing that's
clearly and blacks and blacks favorite
this is what i should do probably king
be a drooly I this is what the comp is
giving and blacks clearly better yeah of
course I've got two fish ships against
two nights this is usually enough to win
the game if you if you don't do
something very stupid if you open up the
position Chloe I'm slowly bishops again
to Bishop lingers two nights are very
strong the position is however
relatively it's very rigid it's not not
an easy thing to do but I have idea Sam
Bishop here a five then C 4 p-5 p 4 and
so on but white has basically nothing i
played this really badly i think that
this was a bad idea that the way it
turned out he got those nice squares
down on c5 and
it wasn't easy to play at all I mean the
computer still thinks is roughly equal
which is may be true but it gets
difficult to play and do the way I
played it it definitely wasn't good
after g5 now I'm in some trouble now and
want to take only five and now it's got
that h4 h5 automatic attack again from
here why does the log better probably
winning check check yeah this ultimately
doesn't work look f8 is a bit too bit
tougher but this is not the main point
of this game I have to refute this
opening plane and this is the thing what
he's doing is just bad you should at
five it's just a bad move order all the
moves before I don't know if you have to
go go for this you're in trouble yeah
maybe it can even improve on g6 the
engine wants to take it wants to play a
sea takes or weekly aid also interesting
a g6 is normal and y'all even but he did
this evolution be sure f6 yeah but this
is this is really wrong the engine
suggestion of Bishop g7 and then f6 rue
create is not better because I get get
to play against this pawn in the game
you manages g45 and then you could keep
the position closed for a long time that
was the main difference there okay well
thanks for watching